now we're going to redefine sine cos and
tan okay we're not thinking about them
in terms of a triangle anymore we're
thinking of them in terms of the unit
circle so I'm gonna say this definition
that you can start writing it but I will
write it as well okay we define we
define cos theta I'm doing this in
alphabetical order because it tends to
be easier to remember we defined cos
theta as the x-coordinate and sine theta
as the y-coordinate let me write that
down so you can write it with me where's
a good spot for it here we go we define
cos theta should be the x-coordinate
sine theta to be the y-coordinate of
what the coordinates of what well it's a
point on this unit circle right of a
point on the unit circle I'm going to
capitalize unit circle just to emphasize
to you it's a special kind of object it
has its origin at the center Center at
the origin and has a radius of one other
point on the unit circle with an angle
theta between okay now I need you to
help me actually finish this definition
there's the definition first let's just
remember what's going on cos theta no
longer has anything to do with the
triangle anymore it's about an x
coordinate of a point same deal with
sine I've named it like this cause and
then sine these are alphabetical to help
you remember that they match with these
which are also alphabetical cause of
sine x and y okay of this point on the
unit circle now where is this angle
mm-hmm where did we draw it now on your
diagram you still have it here okay
so the angles between two different
lengths it starts from here and it goes
up so how would you describe this length
down here what names could use remember
I'm trying to get away from triangles so
I no longer have a triangle my diagram
anymore but I have all these other
objects that I can name how might you
describe this length over here okay I
can describe it as the radius but
there's lots of radii in this circle so
is it a particular radius which one okay
so I can say positive because look it's
on this side but um this is also
positive isn't it so write positive I
should probably say positive X right
because that's the direction I'm going
you so this angle theater is between the
positive x-axis and where does it go up
to what is the blue line I've just drawn
its another radius right but which
radius is it how would you describe it
with words it's the radius to where you
are right now it's the radius to this
point that's probably the way that I
would say it so the angle theater is
between the positive x axis and the
radius to your point okay now you're
going to need your calculator for a
second here this idea now sort of breaks
the trigonometric ratios free of
triangles when you make them
trigonometric functions
we're not functions are you just put a
value in and you get a value out okay
now we're going to use our calculator to
test some of these things in a second I
want you to help me before we owe and it
just been off too long I want you to
think about a point like saying that see
that point there don't think about trig
tell me what the coordinates are tell me
what the coordinates at that point one
zero very good because
you know it's x-value and it's not up or
down at all so the y-coordinate is 0 but
what this suggests is that that's cause
of some theta and that's sine of some
theta
what's theta for this particular spot
I'm gonna measure theta between the
positive x-axis and the radius to that
point so what's the angle between this
positive x-axis and watch carefully this
radius to that point what's the angle
between them zero so what we're
suggesting is that that is cos of 0
degrees and that is sine of zero degrees
now that doesn't make sense when you're
in a triangle does it because you can't
have a triangle with zero degrees but
I'm not thinking of triangles anymore
I'm thinking of this guy now go to your
calculator go ahead and punch in cos of
0 and what you should find it faithfully
gives you back is 1 and then sine of 0
go ahead put it inside zero in your
calculator is zero okay are you getting
it you see what's going on okay all
right well I stay with me it gets better
it gets better
okay regather Rogalla think again now
have a look at this point up here what
are the don't worry about trig just tell
me what are the coordinates of that spot
up there 0 comma 1 what is the angle
what's the theta that goes with that
point what's the angle what's the angle
it's between the positive x-axis here it
is and the radius to that point what's
that angle it's 90 degrees
now before you reach your calculator 90
degrees does it make sense in a right
angle triangle does it because you've
already got one 90 degree angle you
can't have another one be 90 cuz then
you've got no more triangle right but
I'm not in a triangle anymore I'm on the
unit circle so that suggests that these
coordinates are cause of what angle was
it again
90 degrees and sine of 90 degrees
and go for your calculator cause ninety
is going to be zero and sine 90 is going
to be one okay now you thought that was
a bit crazy okay
it gets better your brain exploding what
okay
again I'm gonna rehearse this one more
time
I tell life this is the second last time
this guy over here right on the left
hand side tell me the coordinates
just the coins negative one now now that
you know I've done this twice already
right after I know the coordinates now I
want to know the angle well here's the
positive x-axis and the radius happens
to be the negative x-axis so what's
Theda you go all the way from over here
and 180 degrees sends you to the other
side now 180 degrees makes even less
sense than any of these things up here
at least you can fit 90 in a triangle
180 can't ever be an angle in a triangle
right but the unit circle tells us that
cos 180 degrees is negative 1 and sine
of 180 degrees is 0 okay now you see how
this is not this is not ratios anymore
how can the ratio be a negative number
you can't have negative lengths on the
unit circle you can it's a it's a
channel you're a badass over here see
the circle say that I didn't hear your
question so you
let's give these names any triangle any
triangle any triangle you like okay I'm
gonna make a line up here that's
parallel tell tell me what this angle is
and why this angle is X because all turn
angles turn what this angle is
because hundred eighty degrees please
tell me you've seen that before that's
the way to anyway okay okay I don't need
me to say anything anymore what
questions should I ask what are the
coordinates and the answer is zero
negative one what's the next question
what's the what's the angle now look
where am i measuring from watch I think
I'm gonna draw it this time cuz so weird
from the positive x-axis here it is all
the way around to the radius and it's
270 right 270 is not in any triangle I
know about but go ahead put close to 70
ang calculator put sine 270 into your
calculator